[Musik]
Luca ja
wieso brummt mein Haus
bist du das ich höre hier nichts ihr
hört doch die Mörder es kann nicht sein
dass da jemand ist die ganze Zeit
ganz kurz ich bin gerade gemutet
im letzten Stream Zombie unter dem Haus
versteckt
du hörst doch jetzt boah ich hör das
nicht oh mein Gott weiß was sein könnte
das eventuell an der Höhle hinten hier
liegt wenn du mal hier runter guckst
[Musik]
oh mein Gott jetzt fällt die auch noch
in Wasser ne ich habe noch ein halbes
Herz danke für nichts Alter du kannst
dich ein halbes Herz haben du bist ins
Wasser gefallen guck mal es gibt nur
eine Möglichkeit Sandra es kann halt
sein dass unter deinem Haus irgendwo ein
Zombie ist und da ist halt die Höhle
aber bei mir jetzt gerade geklingelt
hatte ich beobachte dich oben vom vom
Dach aus ich würde einfach mal alles so
ein bisschen absuchen ich muss nur eben
kurz mein mein Essen entgegen
[Musik]
meine ganze schönes Haus kaputt
ich höre schon lauter zweiten sind ja
bis später
was passiert Luca unter mir waren Zombie
Leute wie kommt er dahin
okay
ich werde das ganz am Ende auflösen ganz
am Ende sonst wird die ja alles
abbrennen antworte mit dieser Frage die
ich dir gerade gestellt habe okay hast
du Luca mir im letzten Stream ja was
meine Garage gebaut habe für meine
Pferde oder vielleicht zu Hause
deswegen sage ich nein sagen nein
habe ich auf Instagram gerade eine DM
bekommen
[Musik]
ja Glückwunsch dass du dir bekommen hast
was steht da drin
er war's nicht alle schreiben das
parallel den Stream dann sehe ich oh
mein Gott Leute jetzt alle auf meiner
Seite alle bitte schreiben Sandra Sandra
er war es nicht alle sonst wenn gebannt
er was er war es nicht
[Musik]
ich komme gleich wieder ne ja kannst die
Leute bisschen unterhalten okay Leute
ich gucke gerade parallel in den Chat
war wie kann ich wie können wir Luca
Pranken soll ich den eingraben wo ist
der denn gerade
keine Spitzhacke
[Musik]
Leute wo ist da wo ist er wo ist der
ich muss schnell bauen
Mist was wir werden
also ich
hast du noch den Kugelfisch
ja hast du Hunger ja dann isst du den
mal
[Musik]
tut mir leid kann man nichts machen
Minecraft
[Musik]
also hinten in der Kirche bist du auf
jeden Fall nicht er gib mir einen Tipp
okay jetzt komm komm harter Tipp okay
ich wollte was hoch bauen was
[Musik]
passiert gerade
hallo
aber hey ich habe dich so lange nicht
gefunden das war echt krass dass ich
richtig gut versteckt
ja ich wollte noch was sagen
Zombie habe ich unter dein Haus gelockt
[Musik]
was machst du
da kommt jetzt eine dicke pferderanchin
die ich heute baue wenn man nicht hier
bitte warum hier habe ich schon einen
Plan und das ist der Blick auf unsere
Stadt da darf nichts Großes hin gebaut
werden bist du der Bürgermeister oder
was Deutschland
wir treffen uns um genau 20 Uhr machen
wir eine kampfsession erstmal
[Musik]
Bruder ist es irgendwie ein Club was ist
denn verkehrt gelaufen was denken die
denn alle wer die sind in unserer Höhle
steht auf einem Block eine Kur auf dem
anderen Block steht ein Schwein auf
anderen Block steht ein Villager
es ist 20 Uhr sein wir müssen kämpfen
die grundlegenden Basics
in Minecraft musst du auf jeden Fall
lernen
oh mein Gott habe ich mich gerade
erschrocken ja es ist eigentlich nur
schlagen
keinen Schild
ja warum warum schlägst du mich jetzt so
ich dachte wir kämpfen jetzt
[Musik]
Teil des Trainings ist nicht dass man
sich gegenseitig tötet würde ich sagen
nee aber das macht doch Spaß
hast du Angst vor mir haha ich komme
Laser
jetzt hör auf zu schießen
du hast doch gesagt wir kämpfen ja indem
ich gewinne ach so das ist nur in
Ordnung wenn du gewinnst ja alles klar
zu schlafen
[Musik]
die hat abgestimmt Leute 80% sagen
Kirche soll gesprengt werden wo soll ich
hin um das zu sehen Lisa an
ich setze das einfach mal mit ich hier
rein
sonst an und jetzt haben wir keine
Kirche mehr
[Musik]
warum Ruine
so sieht Köln in etwa aus falls ihr euch
fragt so von der Architektur guck mal
wie schön du den Baum hier mit dem Ding
eingezogen haben warte mal muss ich mir
jetzt erstmal kurz zum privates pick
machen hey Leute ich beende dann jetzt
die Stream für mich ne ja Tschüss ne
tschüss Stream Ciao Sandra sagen tschüss
ja was soll ich machen jetzt können wir
noch was vorbereiten fürs nächste Mal
wenn die Ideen habt wie ich die Pranken
könnte jetzt noch sie ist ja gerade
nicht mehr auf dem Server schreibt mir
gern
[Applaus]
ich will dir nichts nichts kaputt machen
bei dir
ich sag das einfach ein Geschenk dass
sie halt viel
Holz bekommt vielleicht ist aber gar
nicht so groß geworden
vielleicht auch doch ist das ein Oschi
TNT unter die Druckplatte Versand das
Haus ins Wasser so das Blöcke kann
damage nehmen auf eure
[Musik]
Kappe geht das andere Sache die ich
gerade noch gelesen habe war Dinner
bauen prank können wir machen wir haben
jetzt Sachen von Amboss
[Musik]
die wird gar nicht klar kommen wie wir
sie denken Lukas hier ist ein Spiel
Fehler oh dieser Fernsehturm okay aber
das auch gemacht so wir Pranken jetzt
nicht mehr Leute wir sehen uns wir hören
uns Minecraft mit loser Ende
[Musik]